you're weirder than I ever thought today
me and my wonderful father are going to
be reading through my tender messages
you're gonna be reading the first
messages that I've been saying to these
girls
you are dramatic sometimes so I don't
know what to expect here together
watching - does that mean you can throw
me over your shoulder and spank my ass
wanna come to church tomorrow well they
didn't reply to that one yeah are you
Moroccan cause you're Moroccan my socks
off
you're like Moroccan girls that will you
laughter I don't think I've ever met a
Moroccan go
are you getting some myths nm you're
gonna be a lonely old man I love your
profile pic but I love even more to see
what's further down your introductions
[Music]
Netflix and chill are Korean barbecue
and some texts that mutual ghosting each
other
how's this mutual ghost community to
scare each other boo are you ready for
your yearly prostrating man it's hot I
could rearrange the alphabet I'd put F
and me next to each other are you but
darling me because I swear that Allah is
calling me in order how would you rank
each season of Arrested Development I
never understood this Arrested
Development it up people that are you a
top or a bottom in terms of dancing it's
kind of like dancing let's do dinner and
my dinner I mean each other we're gonna
do each other's fake nude photos of me
that's actually well sick this isn't
this is an inappropriate enema what did
you I'm surprised at you pretty serious
did you not say this to mom when you
guys know you can die a lonely old man
all by himself
gosh I'm really blown away by all this
it's a little dramatic it's a little
dramatic bit it don't show your parents
this stuff we have a long talk
definitely glad I do that was that home
anymore you need to move back we might
need to see a specialist I read for the
future
[Music]